did I love confident white dude dancers
great I saw a video here that I wish I
could find the original one I found
because on YouTube I can't seem to find
it
but it was just a video of a girl doing
this most spastic weird fun sort of but
like dancing and it said EDM shuffle
dance girl EDM shuffle dance girl yeah
and I that's what I remember just like
the key words to remember I can't find
the original when I saw on Facebook with
a I just looked it up on YouTube and
washed it it's I guess high on Molly
EDM dancing is this the girl know bring
Russia though another one doing it I'm
top five shuffle vines but this I didn't
even know there's a whole culture of EDM
shove if you're aware of this at all
whoa it really it pretty much starts at
the running man running man's a lot of
it there's moving their feet they have
they have glowed up feet you don't have
to although black looses he does own a
pair of these black Lou do you know how
to dance like this no no not at all
it looks like crip walking your crip
walk your crib does
you are clip whatever we have to get
these shoes well throw Christine so
you're saying you have a leg up cuz you
not a krippwall can we I don't like I
don't like these are too good making me
upset like we shouldn't try although I
would still want to or I'll actually
looks like well I think we need these
shoes we'd all I'm seeing is we need
shoes you don't need the shoes at all
that's just the this kids awesome these
people are too good at it I want to see
the ones that are all whacked yeah too
bad because this is hard to watch
because it's like I can't do that now
dude look her but yeah Dan look at me
you can do it yeah I see someone bad do
it there's no way to do it wrong oh my
god they're doing choreograph your vines
this is the way we should do this is
people showing off swinging dick
I want to see idiots at home doing
I want to see bad versions of this
shuffle fail compilation beautiful blast
it
shuffle fail yeah this is me this is
what might happen in the studio yeah is
he doing that bad yeah I don't think
it's good you don't i think it's that
man carpet he's gonna be in some trouble
catch a lift
Oh is Stefan Stefan Oh how's this a fail
doubt it that's outside here he busted
the things there's a bunch of fail all
you can do the horse yeah but you can do
whatever you want as long as your legs
you're just going flippy-floppy
non-stop from the second you start so
you know I think I'll do the happy
prospector keep your hand work for your
hand works gotta be minimal Oh like that
oh this is Riverdance I think it's very
vital Christine stop confusing the
situation stay with shuffle dancing oh
yeah this is me there you go that's
gonna be you - I agree your assume
you'll be something like that and
somebody gonna think you did a complete
straddle split oh yeah that's me is a
guy falling on his back and staying
there here we go
this is whenever you try it outside of a
school ground you know you're destined
to up all right I could do this
yeah these are all this is how I feel
it's gonna go yeah muster on the Barrens
yeah this is great cuz it's slick force
he's in trouble got a whole
entertainment centers going down at the
bonfire SXM well tweeted out uses da
come on that's in a fail compilation you
don't fail this a lot hey could you go
to the parking lot so you could fill me
doing some shuffle dancing let's look
he's fighting wind it's actually pretty
awesome is this the reporter stuck in a
hurricane yeah man I think we could all
do this nobody in this room gets out of
here without shuffle dancing - I'll go
first
you think I'm scared this song or dance
to this song
it looks so fun it looks like you're
doing nothing and you got to take your
shoes off it looks like so you get
caught doing in an elevator
yeah stop after you get promoted hey hey
hey sorry some thumbs gonna straight
down in the lobby I just got the Johnson
deal do we know what songs these are hey
hi II know that's terrible
actually that's not bad a lot of these
girls end up in fart porn
oh jesus H all right we gotta pick out
some music I get it it's gay it's sock
dancing I got it North America it's
North American Soccer ancing you don't
have to suck you don't be a Sox guess
who's gonna be inside your socks maybe I
should go Sox - yeah oh yeah watch out I
bet I break a big toe by just kicking
the crank my foot yeah we do have an
ankle brace Troy from Philadelphia just
said we don't ccall but thanks for the
culture he goes I because I go to eat
EDC events and you won't see anyone he's
saying you won't see anybody up
doing that yeah you can't if you're
up you're going over right away
they won't even know you were trying to
do that let go looks like they can get
his legs under mop he's down he's down
it was there like he can't get his legs
under oh he's doing the dance listeners
you look you don't your legs honey you
don't who's gonna start this off DJ low
I can't be DJ low it's gotta be one of a
say I'll try Jacobs gonna be a great one
you go first you can go first you're
gonna go for that I think I'll be
terrible at it we're all gonna be sort
of terrible yeah but I'll stop but put
your heart into it you can't move your
hands no you can't look do you feel
removing hand but just it's mostly it's
a it's a foot based situation you can do
it over here
yeah we'll swap spots you get at least
use my headphones everyone dancing has
to use my headphones already I got it
Jacob come on what are you doing also we
got to bring the mic up I thought you
were talking about like square dancing
line dancing you know me I'm a country
fella Oh cowboy oh I came prepared to
boot scoot I didn't know if I would have
known I would have trained for this
let's try this out let me watch a
video - no are you in socks way get
those no you're you're don't stare some
say you don't overthink it just go
haywire with your feet man
get the chairs out of both those chairs
out of the way put one in the hallway if
we got oh we're good
I want that one gone that's gonna be at
space that's prime real estate right
there my special sunglasses Dan yeah
yeah thank you
I'd be careful don't make make sure you
don't kick the console and break your
toe all right start it off again so I
can get into it Danny Sodor let be
[Music]
have some style with it you're really
clunking around I mean you know where's
your grace fair enough is true looks
like for two days I tried that was me
husband bad that wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't it good and now it wasn't good
but I'll tell you this
those old football I mean we got two
cameras on it
she mean you bookend it or should I go
how about I'm yeah you go last cuz
you're gonna be good at it so why would
you believe that why don't I move to
that mic someone's got I got to talk
where you come around I don't know Jacob
just panics well Jake it's hid yes yes
I'm not good at this dancing but hey now
don't play it up so negative you did
good I was way proud of you back there
um so who goes next then I don't know
who wants to go next
blue serve by Jacob oh man I really hope
I love it
I'll tell you this if you don't school
me you're terrible oh one of his
multiple layers is coming off yeah you
gotta go soft
oh yeah yeah guys if you guys are gonna
him
EDM shuffle dance if you guys want to
take this thing seriously like what it
is which is a real live radio show that
is doing some demon smell like onion
left drop a beat for me
right street he's not stopping he is not
stopping he can't be beat he likes the
arms behind the back here it is push it
push it push it
I want to remember this is competing for
the gold in Ring Pop Oh
Dancing's per meter he's outlasted me
Jacob is still moving it's nice there
yes I love it love it
there's no time I mean you feel till
your heart stops telling I mean not yeah
I did five seconds you just Luke Perry
that you just eight seconds it whatever
so Christy Christy dances yeah
black Lou are you about to jump in next
or white Lou which one of the losers
next Christ
sons of bitches killing me are you going
you're next
sure yeah you gotta go you gotta go
Christine we all have to do it we're
rolling rise races like God let me hurry
fine finally somebody somebody knows
what's going on yeah let's see I mean
Jacob's a hard act to follow
I set the bar low then Jacob just
slammed oh you're gonna get Joey
Lawrence doing this dancer you're
here it is yeah kick out kick
out she's got one good move she's really
going back to that way
[Music]
right now Jacobson first christine's in
second and I am leaving not leaving that
was in Mikoto if that was a mechanical
bull contest you wouldn't have gotten
late from the fattest guy at that bar
with that the way you quit
no that was crew everyone started off
strong and their Christmas wit she knew
that move in hey whatever happens if it
gets past I don't know seven seconds
then she was like I did not it's like
holding Tyson to past six rounds you're
like he's gonna gasps he's gonna gasp
just black lower white low which white
white Lou first black Lou we got to make
you an intro so we could sub you into
black alright you ready
[Music]
no no no
[Laughter]
no you can't quit that quick holy
that was funny that really rattled those
were strips of trial Oh laughing in my
face I never did you allows you bailing
on dancing you through your armor you
were but you start to flamenco right
he's right last night laughing oh you
gotta get out there and you have to
dance Lou aren't you embarrassed that
you made one oh my gosh disintegrated
what my favorite things I've ever seen
in my life
dancing we laughed at you bailing on the
dance
I mean fleeting anything I've ever seen
like this it's raining from Scott should
we do a stew day and have them dances to
dance sober apparently everybody if not
you're going through a hedge man I don't
know if you've seen what's going on it's
fine little feet movement black Lou are
you ready you're not ready yeah you
ready you're born ready
jinx kiss you still got to go Big Daddy
yeah no we're bookended I'll be out
after black
so glad I'm done so going on stage right
little how good does it feel to be done
I'm gonna start isn't it nice be done
Lou that was so great
all right black Lou's coming in yeah
they have softer bones for more rhythmic
moving oh here goes
oh there's shoes on side to side
Jacob you got some competition dude and
black lose Hardy he's gaining on him
there it is no don't
yeah I'd say what the hand sucks work
huh he does and he's doing a lot of tilt
on the lows a tilt glow stick ready yeah
oh yeah almost the Russian thing I mean
it's definitely between black blue and
Jacob it's definitely between you guys
might have to get dude someone's about
to get certainly get Street hood in here
suburb yeah you know how I like it
the berm of the hood you know like the
outskirts tuck where you still get
affordable places but it's like you know
nicer Hispanic families young parents
young parents you know how I keep it
young great Street all right you ready
you ready to do this this is the last
one and I think it's gonna come - great
job black Lu I think it's gonna come
down to Jacob and black Lu if J yeah you
know I don't know I don't know what you
did I was very impressed with black
wanna be light on my feet I take it
you're gonna take out your chain and
yeah - wait are you gonna keep the
change from for movement chainstays ha
dude I really like where this is going
I definitely think yeah you got to worry
about her
we got a laptop right there and you good
enough you feel like you got space J if
you don't you're not feeling the song
just tell him to change it now will ya
dunk yeah I need like that
yeah flare flare flare up move the flare
outside this side you definitely out of
the two of us you want that me and you
yeah of that me no I think my face look
frightened the whole time I'm going
through a window I'm gonna go through a
window I felt like I was trying to talk
you over a tight white tightrope walk
like hey I was like come on come on
where my out kicks good you're out kicks
are great it was that was your Christine
move out kick I did go back to the well
a lot yeah you did you were doing out
kick but by the way I was just doing
foot shuffle I went back to the world
the whole time - it's definitely black
Lew and Jacob are the two best EDM
shuffle dancers I just need slippery
slippery or surface yeah I think you get
hurt that way though you get below me up
I mean do we want to do we want to keep
this you got surf style between black
blue and jelly black Lou are you ready
are you ready to keep it we're going to
keep it straight
you know you know how I like it
I said a breath third wall I'm out of
breath I'm worried I'm having a heart
attack say horseradish chips and then
danced real quick yeah that's how
unhealthy these headphones yeah you
can't take your own headphones dude what
are you doing yeah yeah
so Jacob will be going first Jacobs the
white Dance Crew
so black Lou let me give you my advice
take it how we always do it straight
serious serious exit you ready Jake
irate near new Tina
oh damn Oh
goes for it I mean feet just a flailing
oh yeah Cirrus sky if she's here right
now she's interested in Jacob he does he
does a good place wherever she said she
just threw some shade at black blue
wherever Sierra sky is she's wet and she
doesn't even know why yeah she's a goner
someone is just roaming it's over I
think it's over good I mean you threw a
lot of shade at him dude yeah you're
welcome
hi Jade what are you thinking about
Jacobs performance it's fantastic it was
fantastic
black blue got a lot to live up to you
really set the bar did you really set
the bar but I feel like black Lou's got
something in his pocket cuz he's like
I'm going back I'm just I'm in my own
head dude you know what man we're
learning this look at me look at me
we're learning this world together dude
that was crazy so I thought you know
what we all learned that uh well we all
suck at this subject yeah man
doesn't even matter the whole idea was
stupid
it was stupid white Lou gets out
even trying ass all the way white Lou
bailed he failed for headphones what
else you get here at hair out a rhythm
your steps are oh man I'm gonna be I'm
gonna breath Jacob can you walk just
right here right here is good oh thank
you sir
there we go this is it black lose
response to Jacob in EDM shuffle dancing
he's meant to bust at work in your face
he just did a turkey walk check ups not
impressed Jacob's not impressed he hits
a slo-mo on him now these lines who is
hard served oh he's taking left anyone
Jacob Fatah
respond it Oh a media kickback
having an interracial seizure get Steve
Harvey in here this shit's gettin too
straight everyone needs y'all need to
chill player someone's gotta street it
down he want you to get Elley when she
out of the way is it gonna be a flip
black who's about to flip now you guys
was breakdancing at the end I think
there's only one way to settle this it's
now Jacob and lose radio show yeah
we're outta here it's now the bonfire
with jig avatar
[Music]
you